[музика]
Слава Україні Героям слава друзі маємо
шалену приємну новину наша броньована
машинка
[музика]
під землею Зараз ми маємо
дорогу тальки
[музика]
я не можу
фіннгауер 7 рівень бронювання
протимінний захист турелі маскування все
що потрібно і пробіг менше 5 тисяч
кілометрів за волонтерським звичайном
маємо перевірити повністю її справність
замінити масла кондиціонери купити
додатковий комплект коліс обов'язково
посвятити а тоді вона буде вже передана
для наших спецпризначенців на передову
такі броньовані авто рятують життя І
дуже потрібні нашим військовим і
потрібно щоб не тільки волонтери але й
держава залучалася до придбання таких
автомобілів на фронт Дякую вам усім
майже два місяці ми збирали гроші
проходили на концерти Софію фадини і
долучалися до закупівлі цього
неймовірного броньовика Дякую всім за то
що долучалися до нашої збірки всі наші
звіти були на наші офіційні сторінці
знову ж таки Дякую це дуже потрібна річ
на передовій і я окремо хочу шалено
подякувати фонду Петра Порошенка за те
що доклалися до нашої збірки і за те що
допомогли привести цю машинку в Україну
Чому так довго це зайняло часу з лютого
місяця як ми збирали ці всі кошти тому
що ми два з половиною місяці чекали на
британську ліцензію три тижні чекали на
польську ліцензію німецьку ліцензію
нідерландську ліцензію це дуже багато
організаційних процесів але нам це
вдалося і вже скоро вже скоро машинку
посвятимо і передамо на передову нам це
вдалося разом з вами разом з неймовірним
народом України